so physics is a huge subject that covers
many different topics going from
galaxies in the depth of space right
down to subatomic particles and if you
don't already know physics it's
difficult sometimes to see how all of
these different subjects are related to
each other so this is my attempt to show
that in a map so this is the map of
physics I hope you enjoy it physics can
be broadly broken down into three main
parts classical physics quantum physics
and relativity
we'll start with classical physics and a
good person to start with is Isaac
Newton his laws of motion describe how
everything made of matter moves of act
and his law of universal gravitation
tied together the motion of planets in
the sky with the falling of objects on
earth into one elegant and general
description he also invented calculus a
supremely powerful mathematical tool
which has been used over the centuries
to drive new physics calculus is really
a part of mathematics but physics and
mathematics are inseparable
maths is the language of physics and you
can imagine it like the bedrock that the
world of physics is built from Newton
also made strides in the field of optics
which is the physics of light and how it
travels through different materials
it explains refraction seen in prisms
and lenses which he used to focus light
and telescopes microscopes and cameras
telescopes enabled us to peer into the
depths of space and observe the world
array of objects there and develop
astrophysics and cosmology optics is
closely related to the theory of waves
which is basically how energy can travel
through disturbances of a medium like
ripples on the surface of a pond or
sound through the air
lights doesn't need a medium to travel
through and can travel through the
vacuum of space but it still follows the
same principles as always namely
reflection and refraction and
diffraction this leads us to
electromagnetism the description of
magnets electricity or more generally
electric and magnetic fields it was a
physicist called James Clark Maxwell who
discovered that these are two aspects of
the same thing
and derived the wonderfully elegant
rules of electromagnetism theorized that
light was an electromagnetic wave
electromagnetism also explains all of
electricity
jumping back a little bit classical
mechanics is related to Newton's laws
and covers the properties and motion of
solid objects how they move when forces
hit them and what happens when they're
joined together like in gears or
buildings or bridges fluid mechanics is
the description of flows of liquids and
gases
using fluid mechanics you can work at
how much lift is generated from
aeroplanes wing or how aerodynamics a
car is fluid mechanics is notoriously
difficult mostly because the motions of
tiny things like molecules get really
complicated really fast which leads us
to chaos theory chaos theory is the
description of large complex systems and
how small differences in initial
conditions can lead to very different
final outcomes thermodynamics is the
description of energy and how it passes
from one form to another it also
includes entropy which is a measure of
order and disorder and basically tells
you how useful different kinds of energy
are energy is a fundamental property to
physics and although I've written energy
here I should have written it everywhere
on this map because everything to the
energy so that's all of classical
physics the picture of the universe we
had around the year 1900 it told us we
lived in a universe where everything ran
sort of like clockwork if you could
measure everything accurately enough the
future was kind of predetermined however
not everything was solved there were
just a few holes in experiments that
hinted at something
the orbit of mercury was slightly too
fast and some strange things happened on
the smallest scales with electrons and
light which were all unexplained
physicists at the time thought that
they'd solve and explain these problems
soon enough but poking at them they
unraveled the new domains of relativity
in quantum physics and turned our
understanding of the universe completely
on its head
Albert Einstein was the genius who
developed the theories of special and
general relativity special relativity
predicts that the speed of light is
constant for all observers which means
that when you travel really fast weird
stuff starts happening like time slowing
down it also states that energy and
matter of different aspects of the same
thing through the famous formula e
equals mc-squared
general relativity says that space and
time are part of the same fabric called
space-time and that the force of gravity
comes from object bending space-time
making other objects fall in towards
them while relativity describes the very
big other physicists were busy at work
on the very small in the world of
quantum physics atomic theory probed the
nature of the Aten and more and more
detailed descriptions of the Aten were
developed from a tiny sphere to electron
orbits to energy levels and then to the
electrons being wave-like charge
distributions condensed matter physics
describes the quantum physics of many
atoms together in solids and liquids and
is where many great technologies have
come form like computers lasers and
quantum information science nuclear
physics describes how the nucleus of
atoms behave and explains radiation
nuclear fission the splitting of Anathem
used in our nuclear power plants the
nuclear fusion which takes place in the
Sun and will hopefully soon be harnessed
here on earth particle physics broke
even deeper to find the fundamental
subatomic particles that everything is
made of and who described in the
standard model of particle physics in
quantum field theory captures all of
quantum physics and combines it with a
special theory of relativity
and it's the best description of the
universe we have unfortunately quantum
field theory doesn't include gravity and
so physicists don't know how to join
together quantum physics and the general
theory of relativity leading to the
giant chasm of ignorance one day in the
future we hope to close this chasm and
come up with a theory of all of physics
we call it quantum gravity and there are
many attempts to do this
some examples of string theory or loop
quantum gravity and there's many more
but quantum gravity isn't the only thing
we observe but don't understand there
are also the major puzzles of dark
energy and dark matter which seem to
make up 95% of the universe so all of
our physics only really describes 5% of
what we know about and everything else
at the moment is a mystery and there are
many other mysteries out there like the
Big Bang and no doubt there's things
beyond that that we don't even know that
we don't know which gets to the lofty
cloud which floats over all of physics
philosophy although many physicists make
fun of philosophy it's the big
philosophical questions that motivate a
lot of physics like what is the
fundamental nature of reality how come
the universe even exists do we have free
well if we're just made of physics well
how do we know that the way that we do
physics and science actually gets to the
fundamental truth of the universe and
just why is all of physics like the way
it is well those are rather big
questions ones which we may or may never
answer but there's no reason to give up
trying after all physicists and not
quitters and that was the map of physics
so that's the end thanks for watching
the video I hope you enjoyed it I'm
still kind of working on the format of
this channel playing around with a few
different things and I kind of like this
animation style so let me know in the
comments if you enjoy this kind of stuff
you want me to do more and if there's
any specific subjects you want me to
cover I'm totally open to ideas I've got
a whole bunch of videos that are coming
down the pipe to keep your eyes peeled
for those
till next time see ya